hey what's up guys my name is a Cherno
and welcome to a brand new series this
series is going to teach you everything
you need to know about C++ we're gonna
learn C++ specifically in the context of
game development however it's not just
gonna apply to game developing a game
programming we're just gonna use games
as an example this series is gonna apply
to pretty much everyone whether you're a
beginner or you're advanced we'll cover
the basics of the language but we'll be
quite concise with that so basically if
you are a beginner you can still follow
along with this series but you're gonna
have to be able to Google things and do
some research and finds find some of the
basics out for yourself basically just
be a normal person and Google things
that you don't understand I don't want
to dwell on the basics for too long and
cover them in extreme detail so just
make sure you google things and you'll
be fine so now the question is why why
would I want to learn C++ it's in C++
kind of an outdated language why what
good is there in learning C++ nowadays
so C++ is still pretty much the most
used language when you need to write
fast code that performs well or if
you're writing for a weird architecture
or a platform and you need the code run
natively if you want direct control over
Hardware C++ is for you the games
industry for example uses C++
extensively and game engines like unity
Unreal Frostbite they're all written in
C++ so the question is why why would we
want to act access to hardware why all
of these game engines written in C++ why
not use another language the biggest
reason for using C++ is the direct
control over hardware let's talk a
little bit about how C++ works so you
write your code in C++ you pass your
code into a compiler and that compiler
will output machine code for your target
platform machine code is the actual
instructions that your device's CPU will
actually perform so using C++ we can
literally control every single
instruction that your CPU executes what
platforms does C++ run on you ask pretty
much anything you just need a compiler
that will output machine code for that
platform for example an x64 compiler
will output x64 machine code and thus
run on x64 CPUs so to give you an
example of some of the platforms that
C++ is commonly used to develop for
Windows Mac Linux any other desktop
operating systems pretty much all of
them mobile operating systems iOS
Android for example you can write
applique
in C++ and all the consoles so Xbox
Playstation and all the Nintendo stuff
like the 3ds the Wii U the switch
everything C++ is great when you need Y
platform support because as long as
there's a compiler you can get C++ to
compile into native code that will run
on that platform of course there are
other native languages out there it's
just the C++ as the one that's been
around since the early 80s and it's just
so popular and everyone knows it that
it's just everyone's using it other
languages like C sharp or Java differ
because they run on a virtual machine
this means that your code gets compiled
into an intermediate language first and
then when you actually run your
application on that target platform the
VM the virtual machine will basically
convert it into machine code at runtime
so picture this if you will pretend that
you wrote a book in English but you want
someone in Germany who only speaks
German to read your book so what you've
decided to do is actually sell the book
in English at the German store however
when you buy the book you also get like
a translator like an actual person to
come home with you I know this metaphor
is getting a bit weird but just bear
with me so the person comes home and
then when the when that German person
wants to read the book the translator
breeds the book in English and then just
basically stops talking in German so
it's like live translating the whole
book for the person that's kind of what
running on a virtual machine is blind of
course it would be a lot more efficient
if you just translated the book itself
into German and then sold that in German
stores so that way it would be in the
native language in German and that's of
course not a perfect metaphor but that's
kind of what it's like to run say boss
blasts versus a language like Java or C
sharp C++ is a native language the C++
compiler produces machine code for that
target platform and for that target
architecture and then that's it it's
there as native code it will only run on
that platform however it's already in
that platforms machine code language so
there's absolutely no translation or
anything required you just run them
which you just push the machine code
instructions
CPU instructions into the CPU and it
will perform all of your instructions of
course just because your code is native
doesn't mean it's going to be fast if
you write bad code in C++
it's gonna be slow in fact it'll likely
even be slower than virtual machine
languages like C sharp or Java because
they tend to optimize things on the fly
a lot better than C++ world so if you're
right bad C++ C++ will definitely be
slower than C sharp or Java and because
of that I mean I love using languages
like C sharp when I just need to write
tools or things that don't necessarily
need me to squeeze every bit of
performance out of them C sharp is a
fantastic language plan but this series
is gonna be for when we actually need
that performance for when we need to
write circles bus so we're gonna learn
all about how to write C++ correctly how
to write good code how to write fast
code so what are we gonna cover you may
ask well of course from the beginning
we're gonna start with the basics I'm
gonna be real concise when it comes to
the basics because I don't really want
to dwell on them too much if you've
never programmed before I still do
encourage you to watch this series but
as I said earlier you're gonna have to
just google the things that you don't
understand it should be pretty easy to
follow the key to learning anything new
really is just to play around with it
and just to experiment with it so I'm
sure you'll be absolutely fine if you're
just passionate about it and if you
actually have the willingness to learn
we'll talk about how to use C++ library
to your advantage and what things to
kind of avoid if you care about
performance we'll talk about how sales
loss actually works we'll talk about
stuff like memory and pointers seriously
this for some reason is taught
absolutely terribly in most cases so
we're gonna actually teach pointers and
memory and stuff properly this time
memory arenas custom allocators smart
pointers move semantics stuff like that
templates and how to actually use them
properly if you know how to use
templates well they're extremely
powerful and they'll make your life a
lot easier we'll talk about stuff like
macros and how to program for multiple
platforms we'll write our own data
structures and learn how to make them a
lot faster than the standard ones you
get with the C++ library we'll even
cover low-level optimization via
compiler intrinsics and assembly such as
writing our maths and SSE and that's
pretty much it will probably cover a lot
of things along the way
if there are specific things that you
guys request or
that probably could involve me talking
to 10 minutes about I might make a
separate video about them just in
general lastly if you want to know who I
am I'm a software engineer who works on
the game engine team at EA Melbourne we
make pretty much the best 3d mobile game
engine out there so the games that we've
recently shipped were Need for Speed no
limits and Need for Speed No Limits VR
you can follow me on Twitter or
Instagram if you want to get to know me
better episodes for this series will be
released around every week or so
depending on my schedule if you want to
support this series and ensure that the
videos get out as soon as possible and
you can do so by going to patreon.com
4/2 Cherno other than that this series
should be an absolute blast I'm really
looking forward to it let's learn see if
I lost correctly I'll see you guys next
week goodbye war